Salut ! Aujourd'hui je suis allé voir une très bonne pièce au théâtre Bo-St-Martin
C'est "Prête-moi ta femme"
écrite et jouée avec...
Sacha Judaszko !
-Et oui, c'est vrai !
Tu sais Fabien, à peine tu me regardes, cela m'énèrves !
:D
Sacha, as tu ton téléphone portable sur toi ?
-Ouais !
D'accord. Y a t-il un code de vérouillage dessus ?
Fabien, tu parles d'un code pour désactiver mon portable ?
-Oui, c'est ça.
Ah oui j'en ai un !
Très bien.
Sacha gardes ton portable dans ta poche pour l'instant
et je vais essayer de trouver les chiffres
de ton code de vérouillage.
Sacha, dans ton code combien y a t-il de chiffres ?
-Il y a 4 chiffres dans mon code.
Ok ! En effet, je te le demande car dans certains codes il y a plus de numéros.
Tout d'abord, pense au premier chiffre.
Tu me regarde dans les yeux, et tu ne cherche pas à me donner d'indices.
Alors je vais te poser des questions
mais tu réponds par "oui" ou par "non" mais dans ta tête.
En fait, tu ne me réponds pas à haute voix.
Alors il faut savoir que souvent les codes commencent par le chiffre 1,
car les gens ont tendance a prendre leur date de naissance, par exemple,
c'est donc plus simple pour le retenir.
Et c'est aussi fréquent que l'on se serve d'une gestuelle.
Par exemple, on peut s'inspirer d'une forme géométrique.
Un triangle, un carré, ou autre...
D'ailleurs Sacha, on voit tout de suite la façon dont tu réagis.
C'est intéressant de voir tes réactions à la caméra.
Alors, je pense que ton code ressemblerait à ça...
Sacha, cela te parles ou pas ?
En fait, j'ai un sentiment "d'aller-retour"
-Oui...
Oui ?!
-Ouais.
Cool :)
-Fabien, non ce n'est pas cool, tu m'énerves déjà...
Je pense avoir raison sur le premier chiffre,
selon moi ton code commence par le chiffre 1.
Je me dis, dans ce cas: si ça commence par un 1
et que j'ai un sentiment "d'aller-retour",
un autre "1" pourrait être en troisième position...
donc maintenant je dois trouver ton deuxième et quatrième chiffre de ton code...
Or, si il y a un "aller-retour", ça voudrait dire qu'il pourrait y avoir deux fois le même nombre...
Sacha, peux tu me donner ton téléphone, s'il te plait ?
Je vais tenter ça, devant cette caméra.
-Non !
Ne t'inquiète pas Sacha,
je vais juste essayer de le déverouiller.
-Tiens, prends-le.
Merci mon Sacha !
:D
Alors, si je le déverrouille, c'est gagné.
clic
Si je vois ton fond d'écran, c'est bon ?
-Oui, c'est bon... tu m'énerves petit chenapan !
Je te rends ton téléphone, merci Sacha.
:D
Mais comment as-tu fais Fabien? Mince alors !
Et d'ailleurs, pourquoi avoir choisi ce code: "1313" ?
-Car je suis fan de Lelouch.
D'accord !
Ok !
En tout cas, je suis très content d'avoir trouvé ton code,
et pour faire plaisir à ceux qui regardent la vidéo,
juste en dessous dans les commentaires,
j'afficherai le numéro de téléphone de Sacha,
comme ça, vous pourrez l'appeler, par exemple pour parler de votre code de téléphone...
-Ouais, vous pouvez.
De toute façon, en général personne ne m'appelle, donc pour une fois, appelez-moi !
Sachez, que la pièce "Prête-moi ta femme" est une tuerie !
Ca fait déjà la troisième que je vois cette pièce en vrai.
Déjà la troisième fois !
Parce que je trouve que le scénario est énorme,
c'est très drôle,
en plus c'est vraiment bien joué,
et le scénario est tellement pertinent,
tellement intéressant,
qu'on a envie de revoir la pièce plusieurs fois,
pour ne rien rater.
Je vous recommande vivement d'aller l'a voir.
-Même Fabien le mentaliste, n'avait pas deviné la fin de la pièce !
Alors c'est pour vous dire...!
Il m'énèrve Fabien avec ses tours !
D'ailleurs, il vous donne mon numéro, alors je vous laisserai son adresse !
Comme ça vous pourrez aller chez lui et l'embêter pour me rendre service
:D
Merci beaucoup Sacha d'avoir participé à cette vidéo.
A très bientôt
et rendez-vous demain à 17h pour un prochain MentalVlog
Ciao !